now it's time for our Friday Follies
segment we've got some hot cultural
topics starting with the growing
problems posed by people pretending that
their pets are service animals in New
York tonight we welcome Fox News
contributor Raymond Arroyo you're not
here Roy it's not it's not it's not
brought the follies to Broadway first of
all I have to say you're not an animal
person so you should be exempted out of
this segment
you don't like animals not even your own
dog man and an emotional support animal
next to me on a Southwest flight it
literally I'm not lying
it was chewing on my shoe so I know I
have a little grievance against these
that how fine they are the numbers of
these emotional support animals have
gone through the roof lor for about four
hundred and eighty one thousand two
years ago to seven hundred and fifty-one
thousand animals now the reason people
try to pass them off as emotional
support animals is because they fly free
okay all you have to do free alert the
airline and present a paper from a
medical professional showing that you
need your emotional support animal now
the airlines are reacting because
they've been mauling people on the
planes they leave droppings here and
there which contaminate that sort of
passengers I've seen some of these
passengers lay they show up in their
pajamas for flight well they have to fly
but not so with the animals read that
statement from the airlines they know
here's the American air Airlines for
America lobby group airlines have
experienced a surge in passengers
bringing animals on board that haven't
been appropriately trained as service
animals this has resulted in our crew
members and passengers being bitten and
subject to other offensive and injurious
behavior oh do they need to lighten up
I'd be sitting next to most dogs and you
know or another this woman tried to get
a peacock on a Southwest airline and she
was denied well peacocks need to fly
that's an anti NBC oh really I've got
one to top you my friend Walter today
said look up an old Wall Street Journal
article we do I'm just gonna read this
and that I have some video for you this
man brought a miniature horse onto the
plane this was the article pox was
traveling with a
miniature service horse in sikri a horse
had a bowel movement on the carpet of
the bulkhead cabins service had to do
excessive cleaning in order of their
aircraft to leave for the next flight
now we found video laura of a woman who
actually had a miniature horse emotional
service via of animal in her home look
it's opening the refrigerator for her
well wait there making your boy look it
can do pretty much anything but it can't
sort of drain with me Laura there's a
lot a bit there's barely enough space
for me at this point I want more support
animals and I like to one woman let me
hold her dog as she went to the bathroom
she came back there's on a Delta flight
she came back and I said can I hold the
dog for the rest of the flight she said
sure I held the dog for them to fly it
was all the way to California you're the
dog support animal you you become the
dogs you're gonna have to wear one of
those things that say do not touch
support go there okay
when a chant is not a chain a chant is
not a chance Democrats seem to have a
little trouble soda Republicans and
coming up with new chants and you
pointed this out because Nancy Pelosi
was at a tax rally yeah this past week
and it was saying that Democrats are
gonna raise taxes on the rich
Republicans are spent you know are
letting the rich get off scot-free let's
hear some of this lame chant we just we
cannot let it stand we won't let it
stand we won't let it stand we won't let
it stand
we won't appeal the Trump tax replaced
the ones that passed it repeal the Trump
tax replaced the ones who passed it
repealed the trunk tax replaced the ones
that passed it repeal the Trump tax
replaced the ones that passed it oh is
that bad these are not transform these
are not great chance Rochelle the one
that dies you can't even remember it's
so long and and you know they could try
to sing it with you know in a meter you
you a change has to be it has to have
rhyme it should have a certain
musicality it should be memorable and I
will add a lovely delivered none of
which you could accuse those past
chances your bullets look at this it
should drive what is this from that from
the chant handbook you know this is this
is the arroyo book of chant I'm sharing
this with you for the first no we won't
go that actually right Kim faced a
chance was kind of lyric well not wait
song to it I want to be bipartisan here
this is MIT Romney listen to this
supposed chant wait was it Romney Ryan
Romney Ryan Romney Ryan an unmemorable
chant
vapenation now we're all vaping vape
shots everywhere I was down in Florida
over vacation and vape shops everywhere
because everyone's getting ready for the
big push for national legalized
marijuana so that's the vape shops are
ready with you you can put the pot in
the in the vape what have you caught
pipe I don't know yeah well the the
chamber the chamber of the vape has a
liquid component now these 63 percent of
young people or a teens and those in
high school believe that the vape
sixty-three percent that e-cigarettes
and vapes do not contain nicotine and
that they're good for your health in
actuality they contain the the liquid
cylinder contains as much as a pack of
cigarettes that the nicotine in a pack
of cigarettes so they're very addictive
and I think you're right this is a
precursor getting them ready to put
other substances into that vape by the
way they're not supposed to be selling
this to people under 18 some
manufacturers require they'd be 21
before they use the vapor how John
Bainer used to be against even medical
marijuana now suddenly suddenly he's in
this like hashtag alternative acre or
acres well it's some pot lobbying group
or pot an advocacy group he's really
advisor he was a big smoker as well as a
merlot drinker maybe he's vaping the
merlot now that might be a good way to
go for him it's Friday it's it's it's
almost on somewhere Raymond Arroyo
thanks so much